india seeks to become a power player in
afghanistan it's hosting a regional
summit focusing on security challenges
including the threat of terrorism
emanating from the country india has
welcomed russia iran and five central
asian nations but afghan representatives
were not present china and pakistan were
formally invited but declined to attend
beijing says it wants to engage with
delhi bilaterally while islamabad plans
to host its own meeting later this week
and at today's talks in delhi india's
security chiefs said the region needs to
work together
we all have been keenly watching the
developments in that country
these have important implications
not only for the people of afghanistan
but also for its neighbors
and the region
this is the time
for close consultations amongst us
greater cooperation interaction and
coordination among the regional
countries
while regional nations meet about the
stability in afghanistan the thalibon
are struggling to provide that much
needed stability and security since
their takeover this past summer there
has been a surge in violence the local
affiliate of the so-called islamic state
has claimed responsibility for dozens of
suicide bombings nathalie bond's
unfulfilled promise of protection is
leaving afghans feeling unsafe
a fragile calm on the streets of the
afghan capital kabul
but earlier this month the city was the
site of a deadly attack that killed 25
people at a military hospital
the latest in a series of strikes by the
so-called islamic state
the taliban insisted things would be
fine
[Music]
the former insurgents are in a tough
spot
when they took power early this year
they promised an end to decades of
violence
but the so-called islamic state of
coruscant or isis k is making that
impossible
isis k hasn't just targeted the taliban
they've also attacked afghanistan's shia
muslim minority
experts say they have thousands of
fighters across the country and they
seem to be able to strike at will
they say the taliban aren't hardline
enough and want to establish an islamic
ruled empire across afghanistan pakistan
and parts of iran
terrorizing ethnic groups like the
hazara people is just one of their
tactics
but it's effective
i get scared that a suicide attack may
occur
because our people are directly under
the threat of isis
whether the taliban can stop isis
attacks is a key test for the government
if they fail civil war could result and
the country could again become a haven
for militants looking to strike the west
for more on this story i'm joined by
journalist ali latifi ali can you give
us an idea of the overall security
situation right now
the overall security situation
afghanistan you know the issue is that
the taliban had promised that once they
come to power the war will come to an
end
and people will no longer have to fear
things like suicide bombings and
targeted killings and
ieds and you know just sort of these
things that that keep people from living
their daily lives and what we've seen
over the last three four months is that
that hasn't really happened um yes
large-scale suicide attacks and things
like that are down considerably compared
to you know the previous 20 years but
they're still not at zero and we still
have you know these so-called daish
forces the so-called islamic state
forces that are posing threats and still
carrying out really heinous really
large-scale attacks that are you know
just as brutal as they used to be over
the last five six years and then you
also have places where there's a lot of
issues with targeted killings where
people feel as if they could be killed
or kidnapped or targeted
or abused in some way
and a lot of them will say like for
instance i was talking to people in the
northern city of mazar you know people
who had been involved in um
human rights who had been involved in
women's rights who had been involved
with the security forces with politics
with certain legal things and they were
saying in a lot of cases it's not even
that we feel that it's the the taliban
that are targeting us it could really be
anybody it could be criminals it could
be mafias it could be ish anything else
but in that because of given you know
what some of these people did they don't
feel comfortable going to the taliban
for assistance because they feel like
the taliban
may find out you know for instance that
they were to
jail domestic abusers or that they you
know worked in the legal system or that
they're part of the security forces and
hold that against them
in some other way so security is still
very much an issue that the taliban have
yet to really figure out
now ali you mentioned that the taliban
has repeatedly promised to provide
security does the group have the
capabilities to handle this type of
insurgency though
this is exactly the question that people
are asking right is is that you know so
far they haven't been able to
because we've seen attacks in kandao
we've seen attacks in kunduz in uh
in in the east and in jalalabad and in
the districts of ningahara we've seen it
in kanad we've seen it in kabul we've
seen fighting in the city of mazar
between taliban and daesh so so far no
they haven't been able to
establish this sense of security and
that's going to be really important for
them going forward because that was
supposed like the two things that people
thought that at the very least of the
taliban come to power that you know we
would no longer have to worry about one
would be corruption and the other would
be security and so far the security part
has not been
all that successful ali let's talk about
the regional actors they all have a
vested interest in a stable afghanistan
india and pakistan are holding separate
summits what do the people of
afghanistan actually need from delhi
islamabad and others what needs to be
done to help them right now
i mean first and foremost they need a
commitment to
aid right and and to making sure that
aid comes in more than anything that's
what that's what people really need is
financial economic assistance because
right now the biggest issue for
everybody in afghanistan even if you're
very wealthy or if you're the poorest of
the poor is access to cash and in a
cash-based society like afghanistan if
you don't have
paper money or the ability to make that
paper money um you literally cannot buy
food
um so any way of getting assistance of
getting aid of of jump starting the
economy again that's
extremely vital to the people of uh
afghanistan in terms of security you
know they need assurances because you
know pakistan iran have both been
accused of aiding and abetting the
taliban in the past
so they need assurances from them that
you know they
will now assist the taliban in bringing
order and security uh to afghanistan um
and then in terms of like somewhere like
india that they can find a way to work
with uh the taliban so that there isn't
some kind of animosity between them um
and that that and that in that way that
you know india as a regional power can
also help afghanistan um in terms of
even finances and economy and things
like that so so they need a lot from the
region and and the region really needs
to all of these countries really need to
come to sort of
a consensus of how they're going to
treat the government because so far none
of them have officially recognized the
taliban but they've all found different
ways to work with them and
you know in a way sort of include them
but not officially yet
journalist ali latifi thank you for your
insights ali
tens of thousands of afghans left their
homes and their families as the taliban
consolidated their control amid the
chaotic western withdrawal from kabul
airport many opted to leave over the
land border with pakistan the country
was already home to afghan refugees the
united nations says there are more than
1.4 million registered afghans living in
pakistan and an estimated 2 million more
are undocumented
and though the thalibond insists it's
more moderate than it used to be the
group has said it will not tolerate
music in public and artists like shams
raheel crossed into pakistan leaving
behind their loved ones fearing for
their lives
this room is where shams raheel lives
and works on the walls there are posters
showing what his life was like before
the taliban took over afghanistan
he was a famous musician who lived in
kabul and had tv performances
but after the coup he feared for his
life and fled to live with relatives in
pakistan
he had to leave his family behind
now he only sees his son during video
calls
[Music]
my son called me from afghanistan and
asked when i'll be home he's only three
years old and he wants to know where his
dad is
i always tell him i'm in a nearby city
and we'll be home soon
he doesn't know i'm in pakistan
my wife also has a lot of questions
she wants to know what she should do now
next door a fellow refugee allows him to
use his room to cook
the taliban has forbidden music in
afghanistan so life has become dangerous
for musicians who decide to
and then i escaped my home country
shams gives his cousin hamza music
lessons
the young man left afghanistan first
shams was able to follow him and now his
cousin hamza covers all his costs
when i called him up in afghanistan it
sounded like he was at his wit's end
i borrowed some money and sent it to him
so that he could come to pakistan
without the help of his relatives charms
wouldn't have been able to be in
pakistan
they've been here for four years already
and have established themselves once in
a while they invite him to dinner
but charm sees no future for himself in
pakistan he has no income and his family
is far away
at least i can get some sleep here
in afghanistan i used to lay awake at
night afraid of what might happen
but i don't have any official documents
here
my visa run out and i'm not allowed to
work
is afraid that the taliban might hurt
his family in kabul
but he doesn't have enough money to
bring them to pakistan
his dream is to take them to europe one
day where they can live together and he
can continue his life as a successful
musician
[Music]